dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I fail this work
is doing something truly remarkable if
we have a piece of audio of a real
person speaking and a target video of
footage it will be time and change the
video so that the target person appears
to be uttering these words Thursday and
one thing I told them is that they're
not alone the American people and people
all over the world are standing with
them and we always will to help families
refinance their homes to invest in
things like high-tech manufacturing
clean energy and the infrastructure that
creates good new jobs not to mention the
job training that helps folks earn new
skills to fill those jobs the results
are clear America's businesses have
created 14.5 million new jobs over 75
straight months whoa this is different
from what we've seen a few episodes ago
where scientists at Nvidia worked on
synthesizing lip sync geometry for
digital characters solely relying on
audio footage the results were quite
amazing
have a look listen up the train yard
warehouses is our main objective now
let's say you and your men will do that
you have to go in and out very quick
this was great for animating digital
characters when all we have is sound but
this time around we are interested in
reanimating the footage of real existing
people the prerequisite to do this with
a learning algorithm is to have a ton of
data to train on which we have in our
possession as there are many hours of
footage of the former president speaking
during his weekly address this is done
using a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural networks are learning
algorithms where the inputs and outputs
can be sequences of data so here in the
first part the input can be a piece of
audio with the person saying something
and it is able to synthesize the
appropriate mouth shapes and their
evolution over time to match the audio
the next step is creating an actual
mouth texture from this rough shape that
comes out from the learning algorithm
which is then used as
input to the synthesizer furthermore the
algorithm is also endowed with an
additional pose matching module to make
sure that the synthesized Mouse texture
aligns with the posture of the head
properly the final retiming step makes
sure that the head motions follow the
speech correctly if you have any doubts
whether this is required here are some
results with and without the retiming
step
I grew up without my father around
without retiming
he moves randomly and appears unnatural
well I wonder what my life would have
been like if he had been a greater
presence I've also tried extra hard to
be a good dad for my own daughters like
all dads I worry about my girls safety
all the time you can see that this
indeed substantially enhances the
realism of the final footage even better
when combined with google deepmind's
wavenet given enough training data we
could skip the audio footage altogether
and just write a piece of text making
Obama or someone else say what we have
written the Blue Lagoon is a 1980
American romance and adventure film
directed by Randal Kleiser aspects of
the sublime in English poetry and
painting 1772 1850 there are also a ton
of other details to be worked out for
instance there are cases where the mouth
moves before the person starts to speak
which is to be taken into consideration
the dreaded arms and ass are classical
examples of that small confines of the
legal community I think it's real
important to keep the focus on the
broader world out there and see that for
a lot of kids the doors that have been
open to me aren't open to them there's
also an important drug correction step
and more this is a brilliant piece of
work with many non-trivial decisions
that are described in the paper make
sure to have a look at it for details as
always the link is available in the
video description the results are also
compared to the face-to-face paper from
last year
that we also covered in the series it is
absolutely insane to see this rate of
progress over the lapse of only one year
if you have enjoyed this episode and you
feel that eight of these videos a month
is worth a dollar please consider
supporting us on patreon you can pick up
some really cool perks there and it is
also a great deal of help for us to make
better videos for you in the future
earlier I also wrote a few words about
the changes we were able to make because
of your amazing support details are
available in the description thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time
[Music]